et êtes-vous active sexuellement ouais
je fais des trucs sexuels mais pas
ça pas
encore je vois alors vous êtes
sexuellement active
[Musique]
super il est obsédé par toi depuis le
premier jour où tu es venu habiter ici
je m'appelle Adam enchantezmoi aussi
Adam il a l'air adorable bientôt j'auris
la maison pour moi tu pourrais tu veux
dire dormir dormir tu as déjà eu des
relations sexuelles il faut pas en faire
une histoire c'est juste un pénis dans
le
vaginas un moyen de contraception non
faudra voir à quand remontent vos
dernières règles je les ai pas encore je
commence à me demander si tu ne voudrais
pas voir un gynécolog sû que ça va maman
Lindy semble être atteinte d'un syndrome
appelé Mr ça veut dire quoi ça Ly
souffre d'une malformation congénitale
qui explique qu'elle est née sans utérus
sans Colin ni canal vaginal mais le
vagin est vraiment un muscle fascinant
il va vraiment falloir que tu les tires
donc je commencerai avec un plus petit
on peut passer à la taille supérieure
avec celui-ci il fait des
merveilles de voir ça comme un
d'entraînement
pouragin mais qu que ce sera pas des
jouets
[Musique]
an je m'appelle je suis une personne
intersexe être pleinement soi-même ça
dépend de nous n'ayz jamais honte de qui
vous êtes moi aussi je fais des
rencontres bizarres il faut pas s'en
faire j'aimerais tellement que tu te
sentes normale je suis pas du tout
normale tu veux arrêter de tout vouloir
réparer je tellement colère de pas
pouvoir avoirenfant et de ne jamais
pouvoir me plainre d'avoir mes règles
avoir 16 ans c'est véritable
enf euh écoute je crois que je ferais
mieux de te laisser avec tout
ça